welcome back to CBS morning's tensions
between the U.S and Russia have
ratcheted up after a Russian jet clipped
an American drone sending it to the
bottom of the Black Sea this morning the
defense department released video of
this incident which occurred on Tuesday
over international waters not far from
Ukraine Russia says the incident is yet
another confirmation of what it sees as
direct U.S involvement in the war but
pentagon's top officials say the crash
is actually part of a pattern of
aggressive and risky action by Russia
this is a 30 million dollar piece of
American Equipment guys and as we wait
for a conversation coming up in just a
moment with Marco Rubio of Florida who
was chairman of the Senate intelligence
committee is gonna have a lot to say
about this we think about the context
here we're talking about a 30 million
dollar piece of taxpayer funded
equipment on a mission on behalf of the
American people over international
waters and you have a a 30 or 40 minute
confrontation with multiple Russian Jets
buzzing it dousing it in fuel certain
certainly having careless disregard for
whether that thing stays in the air it
doesn't and now it rests at the bottom
of the seat and we're racing to recover
it and we know that U.S defense
officials had conversations with Russian
defense officials yesterday having done
that in almost five months so you could
tell and you can see from what's
transpired over the last 24 hours that
the tensions have been ratcheted up yeah
and on this busy morning I'm told we are
now joined by Senator Marco Rubio of
Florida he is the top Republican on the
Senate intelligence committee and a
member of the committee on Foreign
Relations uh Senator good morning as I
was just describing to my colleagues
here this certainly feels like a big
deal over the Black Sea not far from
Ukraine 30 million dollar piece of
American Equipment sent to the Bottom of
the Sea has the gang of eight been
briefed you're part of it and how should
the U.S respond
well there's been no additional
briefings from what's been made
available publicly but I think a couple
things are important here the first is
this this was a deliberate effort this
wasn't some accident it wasn't some
harassment effort that you know went
awry that this was a design they
basically decided we are going to begin
to shoot down
U.S assets you know whatever's flying
and what they call restricted airspace
it's over international waters
International airspace but they declare
a restriction over it for whatever
reason they want to conduct military
operations and and they're saying
anything that flies in there we're going
to shoot it down so this is a direct
test of the Biden Administration to
trying to see what the limits are and
it's a message of their displeasure but
more importantly I think it's a test to
see if we'll respond to it it will
continue to fly or if this causes us not
to fly in that area anymore
well Senator you're talking about
intentional harassment and a decision to
shoot down uh an American aircraft what
should happen how should the U.S respond
I think our response should be to fly
more of these in that area and to
potentially have them escorted by U.S
fighter jets who are manned and have the
capability to respond these are these
are unarmed plant platforms they're
generally out there for reconnaissance
to see what's happening in the ocean to
have a situational awareness of what's
going on in the area totally according
to international law and so I think we
should fly more of them we shouldn't
stop Flying them and in many cases we
should be prepared to scramble Jets and
respond to they are threatened by
Russian aircraft
okay of course the larger context here
is the war between Russia and Ukraine we
are backing Ukraine but recently
Governor DeSantis of Florida your home
state uh has said that that is a
territorial dispute and not directly in
the interest of the U.S that support for
Ukraine what do you make of that
well I think those of us who support
some U.S role and what's happening there
have an obligation to explain to people
why it matters look Ukraine is not the
most important national security issue
facing America but it's not unimportant
there is a vital interest involved here
and one of them is that we haven't just
invested money in Ukraine we've invested
our Prestige and our credibility and the
argument the Chinese are making is that
the West is in terminal decline the
United States is rapidly declining once
great superpower and they're not going
to do anything they're not going to take
on China so if we were to cut and run
now if we were to walk away from our
commitment to Ukraine the Chinese would
point to that and say to our allies how
are you going to count on the United
States they're not going to be there
they abandoned in Afghanistan
chaotically and they didn't do anything
about you they couldn't even sustain an
effort in Ukraine against Russia so I
think what we need to do is determine
what is it that Ukraine needs not what
they want but what do they need then we
need to determine how much of it can we
afford to provide we need to make sure
none of it is misspent and we have to
get our allies particularly rich
countries like Germany to do more and to
do their part in that endeavor but I
don't think our interests there are zero
and so our effort there should not be
zero either
Senator it's a Vlad let me turn to the
economy now and ask you about these
recent bank failures which have
resurfaced some criticisms of a law that
ease regulations on small Banks back in
2018 the Dodd-Frank Reform Act of 2018.
you voted in favor of that act it was
bipartisan we should point out you had
liberals like Barney Frank and Chris
Dodd were in support of it but was that
a mistake
No in fact I think you'll hear today
from officials at the federal government
within the bite Administration that that
law that passed and the provisions
they're in have nothing to do with why
these Banks fail this this Bank failed
for very simple reasons it had it you
know the way Banks make money is they
make money on the loans the in the
interest they make off the loans versus
the interest they have to pay depositors
they had a bad balance on their hands
right they didn't have enough loans with
enough interest and the ones that were
locked in at low interest rates and they
were having to pay higher interest rates
to their depositors it's also a very
unique Bank it had over 90 percent of
its deposits were uninsured meaning over
250 thousand dollars and they were
heavily invested and reliant on a
handful of Industry startups and tech
companies both of which are going
through a tough time right now because
of the economy and so forth so the
question we really have here is are
there more Banks like this out there
um and and what are the systemic risks
in those Banks but I don't think you're
writ large the majority of uh the
mid-sized Banks Community Banks across
this country don't look anything like
what Silicon Valley Bank looked like I
think the real question is why did it
take the San Francisco fed and and other
agencies out there so long to spot this
imbalance and this quirky situation of
their books at that One Bank
so that is a good question so what needs
to be done so that it doesn't happen
again well I think we need to learn more
about how we got here right so for
example over the weekend it appears over
the weekend that there were a number of
private buyers banks that were willing
to step in and buy the assets of this
bank and absorb it in the Federal
Government Federal Regulators blocked it
I think that's a very good question if
that really is the ideal outcome here is
for the bank to be bought by someone
that absorbs them into a broader
portfolio because the bank does have
good deposits and good assets it's just
that they're mixed and the smaller Bank
was not good why did the government
block that and instead now every
potentially every American with a bank
account is going to have to pay higher
Bank fees because the way you recover uh
these insurance payments that are going
to have to go out to guarantee these
these uh these accounts the way they're
going to pay for that guarantee is
they're going to assess all the banks a
fee and those banks are going to pass
that through to banking customers so
people that have nothing to do with that
bank that have small deposits could
potentially be paying higher fees as a
result of the mismanagement of One Bank
Senator it's Adriana you have been on a
clock Crusade fighting for daylight
savings I wonder a how you felt about
changing your clocks on Sunday and B do
you think you can get it done this year
after the bill that passed in the Senate
died in the house and were you rushing
to the interview this morning because
your microwave clock at home is still an
hour behind
I forgot my belt that's why I had to go
back and get myself even though you
can't see it right here but look here's
the thing about it I don't know why we
keep changing times back and forth we
should just pick one and stick with it
the one that we have eight months out of
the year is daylight savings time I
happen to like it because you know one
of the big problems we have in a lot of
parts of this country is kids can't do
anything after school because if you
don't have a park with lights then you
know you're you're out of business by
four or four thirty five o'clock that's
a huge problem it's a huge issue in many
parts of the country other people
disagree they like it the other way
around my whole point is let's stop
switching back and forth let's stick
with one and if we're going to stick
with one let's stick with the one we
already use eight out of 12 months and
that's daylight savings time now can we
pass it this is Washington someone
always has a reason to be against
something yeah so but it's not partisan
it's more I don't even know what you
call it but you know the answer is we'll
see I mean it doesn't look right now
like uh we have the votes to pass it but
we'll keep trying
we'll keep we'll see thank you so much
Hunter Rubio and we'd love to have you
back to talk about Tick Tock because
that's another bipartisan issue here
yeah